die folgenden zehn sind alle
bloßgestellt und sein ironisch
verstanden werden ich hoffe ihr versteht
diesen spaß meinerseits wenn eventuell
noch ein weiteres tutorial wollt dann
berührt einfach den daumen hoch button
danke so hallo freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu meinem ersten troll
torhüter stirb na gut kommen wir zurück
zum thema und zwar ist da oben eine
fledermaus die fliegt aber schön ein
spaß
ich zeige euch heute wie ihr in
minecraft ein unglaublich schönes haus
bauen könnt und zwar zeige ich euch das
ganze anhand von einem beispiel was wir
jetzt gerade eingeblendet seht ja und
ich werde euch zeigen dass sich das auch
nachbauen kann und wie ihr euch das ganz
einfach selber in ein paar minuten zu
hause selber bei euch in minecraft
selber nachbauen könnte dass sie das
dann selber auch spielen kann und dann
selber bräuchen der minecraft welt hat
habt ich entschuldige mich für einige
recht schreibt bzw grammatikfehler weil
hier sind hühnchen ja ihr seht schon in
meinem inventar aller items die wir
dafür benötigen um dieses schöne haus
was ihr jetzt noch mal ein gelände seht
machen
da habe ich zum beispiel erde er der
erde und pflastersteine
ich bin natürlich im survival mode das
sieht man ganz klar hier ich habe
zweifel maut an hab die ganzen sachen
gerade geformt damit wird die auch nun
alle anwenden können
und ja
ich hatte der anfang bei solchen bei
solchen sachen ist immer sehr sehr
schwer und zwar muss man da immer ein
block setzt und die muss man sich ganz
genau überlegen weil in minecraft ist
das so dass wenn man einmal einen blog
gesetzt hat dass man den nicht mehr weg
machen kann
das heißt ich kann jetzt hier ein block
setzen und jetzt muss ich das haus auch
dementsprechend ausrichten weil ja da
ist die sonne
ja ich habe jetzt hier ein blog gesetzt
das ist bei der eben haus was jetzt
gerade nochmal eingeblendet seht jetzt
ist wieder weg jetzt ist wieder da ist
dass jetzt auch rechts ein blog den den
sätzen einfach hierhin ich mache das so
ein bisschen selbst modifiziert für mich
wir versuchen das natürlich
weitestgehend dann einfach nachzubauen
nun ist es sehr wichtig dass wir hier
genau 123 57 38 69 genau einfach
siebenbürger abstand also hier 137 sind
7 blog was ist denn damit jetzt passiert
diese ist jetzt grün
egal das sind die neuen texturen in
minecraft die machen das das spielt
natürlich dann auch call of duty eine
große rolle darin die haben bestimmt
auch ihre finger im spiel
na gut die beiden blöcke wirklich so
weit auseinander 7 blöcke hier genau
erzählen kann es dann natürlich klar im
vorteil 7 blöcke lernt jedes kind in der
grundschule und dann um die um die
bestimmten kurven reinzukriegen weil wir
können das jetzt natürlich nicht überall
7 blöcke auseinander machen machen wir
dass sie einfach zehn blöcke auseinander
hier so ihr seht schon leisten abstand
von zehn blöcken das sieht man ganz klar
und den abstand von sieben blöcken ja
das sind auf jeden fall schon mal die
stützpfeiler
nun greifen wir durch unser inventar ich
wollte ich habe
nun greifen wir durch unser inventar
ganz einfach auf den pflastersteinen der
natürlich komplett einfach einfach
auszug einfach auszuwählen ist und nun
ergänzen wir auf die erd- blocke noch
einen pflasterstein der dem ganzen einen
einen gewissen touch die touch verleiht
damit man immer schön rausgucken kann
habe ich mir gedacht das vergessen hab
ich gedacht da nehmen wir einfach glas
weil glas ist ein stoff durch den
kammern auf jeden fall auch wunderschön
durch gucken weil wenn man dann einfach
mal zu hause vom mann ich drück immer
auf die tasten drauf weil wenn man
einfach mal so zu hause sitzt dann dann
möchte man durch das glas natürlich auch
durch gucken scheiße jetzt komme ich da
nicht mehr rein
fakt ist mein also man kann die an
minecraft springen aber glas es ist eine
sache da kann man nicht drüber springen
deswegen muss ich jetzt schaffen ja
genau also das ist echt schwer wenn ihr
die gleiche welt hat wie ich
der sieht ist das hier geht gerade mich
also ihr könnt nicht springen deswegen
müsste hier drüber und ich weiß nicht ob
ihr den skill ab wie ich aber muss man
dann ja gucken
jedenfalls ist unten glasschicht auf
jeden fall und über die glasschicht
packen wir einfach dann nochmal unsere
tolle dirt erde erde tripper ihre e mail
merkt das schon immer wenn ich da so ein
paar blöcke falsch setzte dann werde ich
total nervös
nun musste halt aufpassen dass ihr beim
bauen nicht in das loch hier ein feld
weil ihr seht schon das ist ein zyklus
da kommt man nicht mehr raus
aber wir müssen da jetzt rein fällt mir
auf weil wir müssen als auch wieder raus
also ihr könnt übrigens auch blöcke
einfach setzen um dann ihm wieder hoch
zu springen
nun bauen wir nämlich einfach das dach
drauf da gibt es einen trick und zwar
könnt ihr da einfach ein blog
draufsetzen dann hier so und dann hier
so
dann könnt ihr die auch nachher wieder
weg machen und dann habt ihr hier ein
wunderschönes dach drauf auf jeden fall
dann habe ich mich jetzt natürlich
verbaut man oh na gut wir können jetzt
noch einzelheiten auf jeden fall ich
mache ja noch sonne glas luke rein so
eine tür müssen natürlich auch noch rein
wartet mal ich bin hier echt wieder
total verplant tut mir leid aber das ist
mein erstes tutorial was ich euch geben
die warte kommen wir nehmen so eine
eisentür das ist natürlich dann besser
so jetzt kann man hier aber auch rein
müsste müssen wir jetzt irgendwie was
vorbauen ermittlern ja genau das ist
jetzt das haus
ihr seht jetzt nochmal eingeblendet wie
es aussehen soll
und das ist jetzt mein werk natürlich
ist meint natürlich viel besser geworden
ist natürlich klar
aber natürlich ist meins auch jetzt auch
gerade viel längeren zeit entstanden als
das was ihr natürlich jetzt gerade
nochmal eingeblendet seht ich habe
natürlich auch jetzt sechs minuten
gebraucht die person natürlich dass
andere gebaut hat die hat das natürlich
ebenso hin geschützen da sieht man es
natürlich schon viel besser aus das
war's mit dem ersten tutorial träumt
uriel oder wie das heißt
die hühner kommen zurück ich glaube die
werden magisch von dem im na ja ich war
gerade in gedanken an meine ex freundin
die die ja